I watch it and think who is this [ __ ]
and then I realize that the [ __ ] is me
and I'm filled not only with Dread but
also shame they got to buy about about
100 books to make that worth it so if we
started a GoFundMe to buy a hundred
books you would live stream you watching
a season of anime
yes okay I'm apparently the kind of guy
who would sell my house for like 50
bucks in a Wendy's gift card only this
is much worse because as I've already
established anime is satanic so watching
an entire season of it certainly means
that I will become demonically possessed
so I have sold my soul here I've sold it
for a few books now the good news is
that technically I never said when I
would watch the anime those details were
never specified I could schedule the
live stream session for like sometime in
the year 2035 I would not be violating
the terms of the deal if I did that but
the bad news is that apparently this guy
did already start the GoFundMe and has
raised two thousand dollars to buy the
books